SPELL OUT KYIV AND WERE
SURROUNDED BY SUNFLOWERS WHICH
ARE UKRAINE'S NATIONAL FLOWER.
AND PERHAPS YOU WERE STARTING
THIS NEW WEEK THINKING THE SAME
THING I'VE BEEN THINKING, THE
SHEER COURAGE ON DISPLAY IN
UKRAINE OVER THE LAST SEVERAL
DAYS HAS BEEN REMARKABLE.
WE ALL HEARD ABOUT THE UKRAINIAN
SOLDIERS ON SNAKE ISLAND WHO
REFUSED TO SURRENDER TO RUSSIAN
WARSHIP AND TOLD THE INVADERS TO
GO F THEMSELVES, HOPEFUL THE
SOLDIERS MAY ACTUALLY BE ALIVE
BUT HAVE BEEN OTHER INSPIRES
MOMENTS, A RUSSIAN SOLDIER
ATTEMPTING TO STOP A TANK WITH
HIS BODY, OTHERS FORCED TO GO
INTO WAR SHELTERS, FORCED TO ACT
LIKE TURTLES AND GO INSIDE THEIR
SHELLS TO SHIELD THEMSELVES FROM
RUSSIAN ATTACKS.
YES, CHILDREN CAN BE BRAVE TOO.
>> SO IT'S VERY IMPORTANT THAT
IF YOU CANNOT GET TO THE BOMB
SHELTER THAT YOU PROTECT
YOURSELF FROM THE HIT, IF IT
HITS, SO TO KEEP YOUR MOUTH OPEN
AND YOUR EARS COVERED SO THIS IS
THE GAME I SEEN ON THE INTERNET,
YOU CALL IT A GAME TO EXPLAIN TO
CHILDREN THAT IT'S NOT LIKE
SOMETHING TERRIBLE HAPPENING BUT
JUST LIKE A SMALL GAME THAT YOU
ARE PLAYING THAT YOU LAY ON YOUR
BELLY, YOU OPEN YOUR MOUTH, YOU
COVER YOUR EARS AND THEN YOU
PRETEND THAT YOU'RE A TURTLE
THIS WAY BECAUSE THIS IS, YOU
LOOK LIKE A TURTLE AND THIS
MAKES IT LESS STRESS FOR THE
CHILDREN.
>> OTHER HAUNTING IMAGES FROM
EUROPE'S PAST, UKRAINIANS
BORDERING TRAINS FROM THE
THOUSANDS.
WOMEN AND CHILDREN CAN LEAVE THE
COUNTRY BUT MEN BEING TOLD TO
STAY AND FIGHT.
PARALLELS ARE THERE.
THIS TIME, THE VILLAIN SPEAKS
RUSSIAN, HE LIES AND SAYS HE'S
THE ONE FIGHTING THE NAZIS BUT
HE'S THE ONE ROLLING THERMOBARIC
WEAPONS THROUGH UKRAINE THAT CAN
VAPORIZE HUMAN BEINGS, FORGIVE
IF I DON'T WANT TO CALL HIM
PRESIDENT PUTIN ANYMORE,
CONSIDERING THE RUSSIAN LEADER
OR HOWEVER YOU WANT TO DESCRIBE
HIM PUT NUCLEAR FORCES ON ALERT,
TO DO WHAT, WE SHOULD ASK.
BUT IN THE FACE OF THAT KILLER
SOMETHING, UNEXPECTED HAS
HAPPENED IN THE LAST SEVERAL
DAYS.
MUCH OF THE WORLD HAS BEEN
INSPIRED, AND NOW, MUCH OF THE
WORLD IS UNITED IN PART BECAUSE
OF THE LEADERSHIP OF UKRAINE'S
PRESIDENT, VOLODOMYR ZELENSKYY,
WHEN ASKED WHETHER HE WANTED TO
BE EVACUATED FROM UKRAINE, HE
SAID I NEED AMMUNITION, NOT A
RIDE.
ZELENSKYY TOLD THE WORLD HE IS
RUSSIA'S NUMBER ONE TARGET, HIS
WIFE AND CHILDREN, HE SAYS, ARE
TARGET NUMBER TWO AND YET HE HAS
DEPLOYED A WEAPON PUTIN SHOULD
HAVE EXPECTED BUT DIDN'T BECAUSE
PUTIN IS STUCK IN THE PAST, A
ONE-TIME UKRAINIAN TV STAR,
ZELENSKYY HAS TURNED TO SOCIAL
MEDIA TO RELEASE MESSAGED FROM
THE STREET URGING HIS PEOPLE TO
STAND IN DEFIANCE OF PUTIN'S
ARMY.
NOW, INSTEAD OF SIMPLY HIDING
FROM RUSSIAN ATTACKS, UKRAINIANS
HAVE BEEN BUSY MAKING MOLOTOV
COCKTAILS TO GREET THE INVADERS,
YES, PUTIN MADE IT CLEAR HE ONCE
TO RECONSTITUTE THE OLD SOVIET
UNION BUT THAT IS THE 21st
CENTURY DEFINITION OF INSANITY,
ATTEMPTING TO BRING BACK A
FAILED STATE THAT COLLAPSED IN
UTTER DEFEAT DECADES AGO.
IF PUTIN IS SO THIRSTY FOR A
FLASHBACK TO THE COLD WAR,
PERHAPS HE SHOULD BE REMINDED
WHAT HAPPENED TO THE LEADERS OF
THE FORMER SOVIET STRONG HOLDS
AT THE END OF THAT ERA.
IT DIDN'T END WELL FOR THE
PROFESSORS, THAT APATHY ARE THE
ENABLERS OF TYRANNY AND
OPPRESSION, IT'S NOT A STRETCH
TO SAY THIS THE A CRITICAL
MOMENT IN DEMOCRACY, UNTIL PUTIN
MOVES ON TO THE NEXT COUNTRY AND
AFTER THAT.
AS SAID, IT IS TIMES TO TAKE
SIDES, TIME TO TAKE UKRAINES
SIDE.
PERHAPS THAT IS BEGINNING TO
HAPPEN, WE HAVE SEEN THOUSANDS
TAKING TO THE STREETS, THOUSAND
FROM MOSCOW, THE REST OF EUROPE
AND ALL OVER THE WORLD.
NOT JUST DEMANDING AN END TO
PUTIN'S INVASION, THEY ARE
STANDING IN SOLIDARITY WITH THE
UKRAINIANS, LANDMARKS ACROSS THE
GLOBE THERE IN YELLOW AND BLUE.
THE UKRAINIAN PEOPLE HAVE LIT A
SPARK THAT IS UNITING THE WORLD
AGAINST TYRANNY.
NOW, HERE IN THE UNITED STATES,
WE MAY BE TEMPTED TO THINK THAT
THE STRUGGLE AGAINST TYRANNY AND
FIGHT FOR FREEDOM AND LIBERTY IS
A UNIQUELY AMERICAN EXPERIENCE.
BUT WHAT WE ARE WITNESSING RIGHT
NOW IS THAT THE FIGHT IS NOT
AMERICAN OR UKRAINIAN.
IT IS UNIQUELY HUMAN.
IT IS